happy monday everyone
all right
this is still the weekend for some of
these people
i hope you had a decent weekend but not
too decent if you know what i mean
good to see bill hammers with us huh
by the way uh thanks for having me over
welcome yeah
so
cute
that is not photoshopped
all right so for the left to maintain
their often unfortunate beliefs they
have to assume the very worst about the
people they claim to defend remember
it's the party that told you blacks
can't get ids
but also the poor you know that they
steal right
yes that's what we always hear at nyc
that and gunshots but whenever goods are
stolen a democrat will say it's because
the people stealing can't afford to buy
them even though the thieves sell the
stolen crap immediately after it's
grabbed remember when the looting took
off after the bail reforms with people
stealing baby formula and diapers aoc
was saying it's because the poor needed
this stuff but if anybody needs a diaper
it's her
because she's so full of
crap
[Laughter]
see i'm grown up of course most poor
people do not steal
how much money you have has nothing to
do with how honest you are
the problem here in new york is clear
stealing is simply incentivized so the
already criminalized simply get more
criminally and i invented that word
criminally
it's not like poor decent people just
embarked on a life of crime because
walgreens got lazy
no we or our liberal da's just made
recidivism acceptable for the riff raff
take new york's infamous serial thief
who led the league in shoplifting bus
with 46 arrests
four more and he gets a free toaster
which is weird because he already stole
seven
now was it his poverty that drove him
nah i'm guessing he drove himself
probably in a stolen lexus
but did he use the products he stole
like every democrat claimed these
impoverished souls would no he'd pill
for drug stores then flip the booty for
cash i know this for a fact because i
bought 12 men in speed sticks off him
what can i say have you ever dipped them
in ranch
dressing delicious
the new york post owned by our parent
company lifealert
interviewed the guy that was a joke
and he said everything that you knew to
be true
he kept robbing only because he could
keep robbing thanks to the soft on crime
prosecutors he robbed walgreens so often
he'd bring in his own reusable bag
i don't blame him if he actually did pay
for the goods imagine the length of his
receipts
those are long
from all this i don't understand it
either isaac rodriguez robbed one
walgreens at least 37 times last year
this guy was on camera more than
kilmeed's been in the last two years
he'll be he'll be actually subbing for
killmead on fox and friends weekends
you can move that down now that's stupid
but he stole everything from protein
drinks to body lotion which when you mix
together makes a delicious yogurt you
also stole toothpaste soap and tampons
yes tampons now this might have tips
them off that this wasn't for isaac's
personal use
but then again men can now have babies
so why not periods
he'd then sell the stolen stuff on the
street or in pawn shops for cash and he
kept going not because he had to feed a
family it was due to the revolving door
justice system that kept him in business
while putting stores out of business
remember this new craze was brought to
you by reforms that got rid of pre-trial
detention cash bail for misdemeanors and
non-violent felonies which includes
grand larceny this is why criminals like
this dude could be caught over and over
only to be released like a lake trout on
a fishing show
meanwhile if you wandered through an
open door at the capitol you might still
be in jail six months later if only
they'd attacked a white house with blm
those law breakers would be home right
now
but 2022 petty and grand larcenies are
up 42 and 51 respectively compared to
the last same time last year and in this
precinct where rodriguez did most of his
shoplifting glam grand larcenies were up
99
that's almost double
thank you
even janet yellen could figure that out
isaac boasted i may have got caught 46
times but i got away a lot more than
that
he finally got nailed for ripping off a
store where there was already an order
of protection against him and that's the
amazing part really that you actually
have to get a letter from a court in
advance in order for them to stop a
criminal how insane is that but this is
how incentives and disincentives work
the left incentivized criminal behavior
with zero deterrence criminals reacted
exactly as you'd expect so you can you
blame the thieves apparently we're no
longer allowed to and maybe that's how
it goes and you wonder what even happens
when the cops decide to interrogate
these perps
okay deborah
i'll keep this brief we've caught you 35
times stealing this week but it wasn't
me though
we have you on tape look
here's a picture of you stealing ties
from jcpenney
that looks nothing like me
this looks exactly like you we also
caught you on camera stealing a monkey
head from the national history museum
i would never wear that you're wearing
the same thing right now you're wearing
the same thing
we also caught you
stealing a male model from the
international house of male mamas he hit
on me
now that's the biggest lie i've ever
heard you expect me to believe that
hey baby
you ready to get out of here
[Laughter]
oh my god
they make a beautiful couple
so
the question is
with all this stealing
going
unarrested is that a word
why are we paying for things are we the
suckers or what in this new world you'd
be stupid not to steal like you'd be
stupid to pay your student loans back
i mean how's that not wholesale theft
it's a government reaching into your
pocket to pay off someone else's debt in
that case you're the drug store and the
government just walked in and cleaned
out the register
[Applause]
tonight yes
she looks like a stock photograph in a
picture frame you buy and pretend she's
your girlfriend
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
i can't imagine how many dog pictures he
has to look at every morning
america's newsroom co-anchor bill hemmer
and this man is so bright he gets kicked
out of movie theaters founder of strive
asset
management or sam and best-selling
author of the book woke inc vivek
ramaswamy
[Music]
and she's like a sour patch kid sweet on
the inside and often found stuck to the
theater floor
for the movie pop zeus contributor cat
tip
bill
great to see you you had a nice 10-day
break from dog pictures
dana's back
oh they're still online greg
she was sending them
i told everybody that she was suspended
from fox so i heard
are you getting tired of hearing isn't
it weird how we do this story over and
over again and nothing happens no i was
thinking uh this is kind of like uh
we're living our own little science
experiment you know back in grade school
when the teachers say hey got a science
fair coming up in two months go home and
come up with a project well they came up
with a project all right all right
includes lenient sentences and no cash
bail and open the border legalize drugs
and make the streets home for the
homeless and that's just new york i know
so we're three years into this
experiment let's call it that okay this
science experiment and we'll find out in
november how people are gauging how it's
going
what if you and i decided to go out to a
drug store and shoplift what would
happen to us this dude was the league
leader
37 times in one shot but do you think
we'd be treated the same or differently
if we did it if we went in can we just
walk out i mean have you ever thought
about that when you're in there i
haven't really considered that greg but
i would suggest that if they're this
lenient yeah you could get away with all
right okay i know what i'm doing by the
way i'm just joking it's just little uh
little uh
thinking out loud
just yes emily very good very good um
you're a lawyer and you're from
washington did you see that people are
no longer stopping
from is it state of washington right the
police are trying to uh they turn the
sirens on you don't have to pull over
anymore that's another incentive to keep
driving that's right and actually the uh
the a similar analogy to that is what's
going on in the southern border which is
that the law states if you're a juvenile
driver you're sort of the law
enforcement there is prevented from
engaging in high-speed pursuits which is
why the cartels have now enlisted
juvenile drivers for them so the point
is it only leads to bad news yes um or
incentivizes all of us driving fast
there
i have to say back on this league mvp um
the irony to me is that part of the
advocacy by the progressive left of not
putting people like that in jail saying
well incarceration is toxic right that
that
it deteriorates humanity but what
happens now that he's in jail he is 200
days left on his sentence he says i'm
now clean i'm sober he's getting his ged
he says i would have died if i had
stayed on the streets he said this is a
blessing in disguise i hope i saw that i
hope he was telling the truth because
like it tells you you have to separate
the person from the life at some times
by the way you can just say get you
don't have to spell it out
[Laughter]
but anyway i i was i was going is this
for real because then you know he's
going to get out vivek by the way i you
know you obviously booked huge you came
at the right time woke great book why
are companies speaking like you don't
really hear the companies that are being
victimized why is that
yeah well look i think that they're just
apologizing to the people who used to
come after companies so they'll say you
know what you can steal a little bit
from our shop as long as you get the
regulators off our back that's still a
pretty good trade right shop fares a
little bit corporate profits different
things so this is a game that the
companies played but you know i thought
for a business guy by the way greg you
got the incentive thing pretty right
there you give people more incentives to
commit crimes they're going to commit
more crimes
i do think there's one more element to
this though and i think it's i think
it's pretty important actually is that
you have a philosophy behind blm behind
clear the jails behind i'll defund the
police movements which basically say the
system is so corrupt the system is so
racist yes that you're actually
justified when you do it you're actually
sticking it to the system you're
actually doing the right thing and i
think the reason a lot of criminals
don't steal isn't just because they're
gonna get put in jail it's because they
feel like they're doing something wrong
right but if they feel like they're the
heroes and doing something right that's
what's actually going on in cities
across the country is you feel like you
have these heroes that are actually
carrying out a justified cause and i
don't think we've been talking about
that enough that's interesting yeah it's
almost an ideology because if you do
believe that this country is hopelessly
oppressive
then doing anything to strike against it
it makes you a hero
cat uh but you're like me right when you
you can do you get that little tinge of
envy when somebody's stealing it's like
why am i paying or you get like why am i
paying for something you're at cvs
you're buying i don't know ointments
whatever talking about me
yeah i buy some every now and then i
gotta get all i do is just buy ointments
yes
ointments are the most underrated uh
product oil-based products i don't think
they're under or over i think they're
just ointment yes yeah
they're exactly what they are well
there's appointment to my ointment and
that is
what is it about the rest of us it's
it's exactly a corollary to people
who've paid their their college tuition
and then somebody gets it paid off it's
just like being in a drug store and that
guy gets to walk out with a bag because
you're going to pay for it it's going to
make everything more expensive it's
there's never been a better time to
steal yes
because
you even look at this guy like he was
famous for stealing yes and in the past
that might have been a big problem
you wouldn't want people to know that
you were the guy stealing the most stuff
yeah exactly now it doesn't matter like
you can honestly
it's a great career there's you know
like you could set up a booth at the
career fair i don't like i'm the guy who
i'm the guy who steals all the stuff and
nobody would do anything yeah you could
even steal the little tent yes that's
right
yeah i think that guy who's making those
tents is making a lot of money right
yeah the cove tents now they have
outside a little tent there up next
[Laughter]
do writers for the washington post have
a worse sense of humor than most
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else